hey tommy you want to come hiking with
me i'm going to walk 17 miles and sleep
on rocks
how about you nathan you like to hike
come on let's go hiking
[Music]
[Applause]
be safe
well it is a chilly wet summer's day and
we are gonna go up there we're doing
some solo alpine survival camping in
bushcraft
i don't have a tent
and i'm gonna hike 17 miles up this
mountain and we're gonna see if i can't
build a shelter where there's no trees
no firewood
also gonna hike to a remote alpine lake
see if i can't catch some dinner
and try not to get eaten by a bear
see this little plant right here
it's called yarrow it's a medicinal
plant people make tea out of it for
stomach aches
this plant right here this is fireweed
the blossoms are edible
a little bit like honeysuckle here in
alaska a lot of people like to make
jelly out of the blossoms
there's a mama moose and two babies
right over there down in the valley
a lot of moose in this area
the moose feed on this willowed you can
see how it's all clipped and broken
that's from moose grazing and biting the
tips off
see right here blueberry bushes down
here are crowberry bushes
there's a crowberry forming
pretty much anywhere in this valley
that's not covered with trees is has
berry bushes
but we're too early for berries come
here in the early fall you can fill up
buckets of berries and the bears will be
out here feeding on berries as well
you can see we still have unmelted snow
up here it's a bit chillier up here in
the mountains
the weather moves quick and weather
forecasts aren't very accurate in the
mountains got to be prepared
look at that cloud coming around the
mountain it's coming so quick
the weather and visibility can change in
a heartbeat in the mountains
[Music]
i'm getting a little sweaty
now i gotta go climb this thing
uh
all right we just went over the top of
our first mountain about 3
500 feet of elevation
and you can see here we got this little
saddle
and another mountain and another
mountain and they just keep getting
bigger and bigger by the way look at
these valleys
see how they're just like perfect bowl
shapes they're like used instead of the
v's you see out east
these were all carved by glaciers
but right there is a parky squirrel
parky squirrels and tarmigan are about
the only game you'll find up here
and uh parky squirrels don't taste very
good it's like eating buffalo wings with
claws and fur
that's my next mountain to climb
now there's no more clear trail here so
i've got to sit and pick my spot i know
i've said it before but the weather
around here just moves so quick look at
these clouds
so previously i was on the northwest
face of the mountain and i'm coming
around the side and this is the
southwest side of the mountain you can
see how much more vegetation there is
there's little trees and bushes and
things like that the berries here on the
south side of the mountain are three to
four weeks riper than the berries on the
north side of the mountain look at this
look at all these berries
not quite ripe yet but they're getting
there
see they're just all over all
blueberries so if you're at the
beginning of the berry season you look
on the south side if you're at the end
of the berry season look on the north
side
so this right here
this is lykan this is what caribou live
off of
you can technically boil this up and eat
it
it's not it's not good stuff
here's some black liking it tastes kind
of like boiled mushrooms but not that
good i don't want to even think about
how many pounds of that garbage you'd
have to eat to survive
it's edible but i don't know if it's
food
well there we go i linked up with the
new trail
check it out we've popped below the tree
line and we've got some cottonwood trees
growing here
cottonwoods love water they absolutely
need tons of water so whenever you see
cottonwoods you know that there's a
river or stream nearby here's another
group of cottonwoods
there's another stream
this is the cotton from these cottonwood
trees if you have a ferrous rod and
steel you can use that to start fire
see this plant right here
i don't know what it's called but it's
got a sap that if it gets on your skin
it'll make you sunburn and blister
really bad
these are called alders
we get them all over the sides and
mountains here
and they are so difficult to walk
through
do you see
if you ever try to get through an alder
patch you'll never want to do it twice
you're getting these elder thickets and
it's really hard to navigate because you
just can't see very far it's another
plant you want to be able to identify
from far off so that when you're sitting
on a ridge planting where you're going
to go you don't go through any alder
patches if you're going to do off-trail
trekking through mountains
the vegetation is often a bigger
obstacle than the terrain
so understanding and identifying the
plants on the side of the hill it's
really important
all right there's the term again
hear it
at time we get out of the state bird of
alaska and very delicious ptarmigan like
to come to these gravel paths because
they need rocks they'll go and swallow
little pits of gravel
storm in their crops so they can break
up seeds and berries
see these small scraggly little spruce
trees these grow in really windy spots
at high elevation you can always tell
which direction the wind usually blows
because that's the side without branches
it's bare on that side bear on that side
bare on that side and the winds coming
right from this direction they also have
these really cool purple pine cones but
if you ever need to build a shelter near
one of these patches always build on the
leeward side of the trees
the snow just barely melted out of this
valley floor look the alders are just
getting their buds that's because that
mountain right there is blocking the
southern exposure so all the vegetation
down here is like a month or two behind
everything else in this valley later on
in the season when all the berries up
there have fallen you can come back down
to this spot and find berries that are
just barely ripening
right there
that parking squirrel over there had a
bird in its mouth
we have a lot of flesh eating squirrels
in alaska
it's about a 20 mile per hour headwind
and it feels like it's in the upper 40s
but i'm keep snacking and i'm keep
moving so my body's staying warm my
hands are a little cold though
we've been heading down this path for
about four hours
so i think i only have about two or
three more miles left to go
there we go that's the destination
i think i'm gonna walk around a little
bit and explore
all right guys here we go this is the
valley where i want to build my shelter
and camp for the night you can see
there's there's no trees there's no
firewood so if i want to go to shelter
i'm going to have to use what's
available and there's plenty of rocks
and you can see here
somebody had the same idea that i have
started stacking up some rocks to make a
shelter for their tent
so i'm gonna go ahead and
use this to build my shelter
all right i got a tarp here i'm gonna
lay it out to kind of get the dimensions
of my shelter
the wind is consistently blowing from
this direction which means i've got to
build this wall up that's going to be my
primary wind break my entrance to my
shelter is going to come this way all
right i think i got my dimensions
figured out time to get to work
[Music]
it is so nice in here there's no breezes
it's nice and warm i'm completely out of
the wind and i've got enough room where
i can sit up easily
now i need to get some water going
look at this water
you know we got clean water coming out
gravity just pulls the untreated water
through the filter right here
fills up my water bottle just go like
that clamps it off only took about 60
seconds to fill up my bottle
that's good tasting water
well i think next on the agenda i need
to catch a fish
but i'll tell you what it's cold my
fingers are a little bit dumb
nice little rainbow a little small but i
hooked him kind of bad so i think i
better keep him and eat him
nice another one let's get them back in
the water here
i just broke my fishing
rod tell you what i'm freezing it's cold
out here i think it's time to go make
some dinner
that butane squirted out so fast it gave
give my finger a little bit of frostbite
[Music]
all right i made up a batch of couscous
and craisins a little bit of rosemary
and basil and salt in there but i'm
gonna go ahead and cook up that fish
[Music]
um
i forgot to bring utensils so we're
improvising with knives and cups and
fingers and whatever we can do
the not having my fork thing is kind of
bugging me and then i remembered that i
saw a plastic fork sitting on the ground
about
a quarter of a mile that way so i ran
and i found it i'm gonna go ahead boil
some water and sanitize this thing and i
am gonna have myself a spoon
this should be nice and sanitary now
i'm gonna take the hot water here i'm
gonna pour it in my bottle
and i am sticking it under my coat
ah
got some strawberry lemon herbal tea
here and it's just warming me up so good
ah my socks are wet
i'll see you guys in the morning
[Music]
my air mat is almost completely fine
good morning i slept okay the wind woke
me up a lot
got this flour and yeast and water that
i mixed together yesterday and just let
it sit in the bag and it is fermented
nicely so we got ourselves
some bread dough
[Music]
a little melted honey and butter on some
fry bread it's gonna be great
this is such a beautiful valley but uh
we've got about seven miles to do this
morning and we're not heading back the
way we came
we came in through that valley and
instead
i'm gonna go out that valley we'll see
how that goes
well there we go that's the ocean that's
my destination
all right see this creek i'm gonna
follow it all the way to the ocean
check it out right there in that little
valley there's two doll sheep
over there on the mountain there's two
more
doll sheep are like rocky mountain
bighorn sheep only they're all white
checking out all these different piles
of poo
looks like coyote to me probably coyotes
come down this trail and he poops every
time he comes down here
check it out there's a bull moose right
there and he can see me i can see him
i actually know a guy who got his ear
bitten off by a grizzly bear while
hiking this trail
so i'm a little keyed up about the bears
plus the visibility is so terrible you
could be right around the corner from a
grizzly bear and you wouldn't even know
it
the bear spray
it's
hey
bear
something came tearing through here in
the brush onto the trail
[Music]
this is why i like bear spray instead of
guns guns are only as good as your aim
bear spray is like a hand grenade i can
be in the fetal position curled up in a
ball spraying this thing
and uh still do some good
hey bear don't mow me now take a sweet
deer it tastes much
better that's doll sheet poo right there
you can see all the liking in it
coyotes bears moose doll sheep and who
knows of what else are all using this
trail
the watermelon berries
not ripe yet but
i can hear a baby doll sheep screaming i
could hear this frantic bleeding like a
lamb in distress
coming from somewhere over here
this right here is mountain ash
the seeds are toxic but the fruit's
edible
it doesn't taste very good though
i'll take it out that looks like a
salmonberry bush
there's a raspberry bush right here
our rose hips right here rose hills are
a good food source in the wintertime
because the berries don't drop off in
the fall
even when there's snow on the ground you
can still sometimes find rose hips to
eat
the arctic lupine is the seed pod it's a
poisonous plant
cottonwood trees right by the stream
there's some more bear poop
i got a great view of the ocean
might see some beluga whales
check it out this fungus is great for
holding a coal or fire you dry it out
and you put a little coal or spark in
there blow on it and it'll smolder for
days if you take care of it
and then you can carry fire with you
when you hike if you're using primitive
techniques to build your fire this is
something you definitely want to have
i do not know what type of berries those
are
this right here is one of the most
deadly berries in alaska the berries
turn white in the fall
and just a few of them will kill you
it's a huckleberry bush
you tend to find huckleberries at the
foot of the mountain where there's a lot
of rain so this plant right here is
devil's club
see they've got all these spines on here
really thorny the leaves of a devil's
club are really big and they make good
shingles for a lean too
i just got a text from becca she's at
our rendezvous point i don't want to
keep becca waiting
well guys there's my ride
hope you've enjoyed this video
hi
it's been fun
but i have got to go sit down and take
some advil if you guys like this sort of
thing make sure to click subscribe we
put out new videos every saturday
morning so i'll see you guys then hey
tom
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching